what i want to do in this video is to
talk about nucleophilicity
nucleo
nucleophilius
philicity
felicity nucleophilicity and this is
really just how good of a nucleophile
something is or we could i'll just make
up a definition right now the ability
the ability
for
an atom let me say an atom
let me write this atom slash ion slash
molecule
molecule to act as a nucleophile or to
give away
to give
away
extra i'll write that in quotes extra
electron
and bond
with
a nucleus or with something else with
i'll say with a nucleus
with a nucleus let me say with
with and i'll just say end bond but
that's you know i want to say with a
nucleus because that's what
nucleophilicity is saying it loves
nucleuses especially positive ones then
it can give its extra electron to it now
as a first cut
if you want to identify
a good nucleophile it should have extra
electrons to give away so it should have
extra electrons to give away so have
have extra
electrons
to give away
to give away and the best things that
have extra electrons to give away are
negative ions or anions so if you were
just you know just at a very high level
something like
something like the fluoride anion
normally fluorine has seven valence
electrons one two three four five six
seven but it's so electronegative it
might be able to swipe off a leather
electron from something else and then it
becomes the fluoride anion so then it
becomes the fluoride anion with a
negative charge and you can do that for
all of the halides you could do that for
chlorine can become chloride bromine can
be bromide iodine could be iodide let me
do one iodine too so iodine once again
it's a halide it has seven valence
electrons it has many many more
electrons than fluorine but if you just
look at its valence shell it has seven
electrons
and then it is also reasonably
electronegative not as electronegative
as fluorine remember the trend goes like
this from the bottom left to the top
right so fluorine is is extremely
electronegative but iodine is still
pretty electronegative it is a it is a
halogen so it will it also might be able
to swipe off an electron from someone
else and become iodide and become iodide
so in general things with negative extra
with extra electrons lone pairs of
electrons and especially a negative
charge are going to be pretty good are
going to be pretty good
nucleophiles and you know another
example that's not a halide is a
hydroxide anion
so
o h this is an example of something that
is a molecule
so o h maybe you know traditionally
water would look like this so
traditionally this is just neutral water
and oxygen has two lone pairs like that
but oxygen is pretty electronegative it
is already kind of taking the electrons
away from one of the hydrogens and at
some point it might just take it all
together and then you have the hydroxide
and then you have the hydroxide anion so
this will look like this so you have
your original two lone pairs just like
that and then you have this pair that's
going to be taken it already had that
electron it takes that electron from the
hydrogen so it now has two more
electrons let me color code it so you
see what it took it took this electron
from the hydrogen and now this also has
a negative charge that's also a
reasonably good nucleophile
and of course you have your hydrogen now
it lost its one electron it only has a
proton in its nucleus so it's just
whenever you see h plus this is really
just a proton there's nothing else to
that hydrogen so that's hydroxide so
these are all reasonably good
nucleophiles in that they can give they
have something to give away they have
extra charge now what i want to do is
think about between these how do you
think about what's going to be a
stronger or weaker nucleophile and here
it becomes a little bit more nuanced
we're going to do is differentiate what
happens in a protic solvent versus what
happens in an aprodic solvent so let me
write down let me start with a protic
solvent
protic
protic solvent i'll make two columns
here protic solvent and then we'll do a
protic solvent
a
protic
a protic solvent
solvent
right over here and once again these are
fancy words but they mean something
pretty simple protic solvent is
something that has hydrogens that can be
taken away or it might have free protons
flowing around an example of a protic
solvent is water or really any alcohol
so water is the simplest example or
maybe the most common
and the reason why we call it why you
might have protons floating around is
exactly this little reaction i showed
right here maybe every now and then
hydroxide anion forms or even more
likely maybe a water takes a hydrogen
from
from one of the other waters one of the
water molecules takes iron from one of
the other water molecules and becomes a
hydronium where it's where it is it's
not a proton necessarily but it has it's
an oxygen
it's an oxygen
that has so let's say if you if you
start with water and this one of these
electrons were to be given to some
proton floating around it would look
like this
and it has a positive charge and then
this proton is very available it's kind
of you can almost imagine it's almost
floating around because that oxygen
really wants to take back that electron
so protic solvent is water in water you
might see a little bit of hydroxide a
little bit of proton a little bit of
hydronium you see all of it in there but
the bottom line is that there are
protons that can react with other things
you have protons that can react with
other things let me clear this away so
that i have some real estate
so let me just write down water
so water
is a protic solvent now you might say
hey wait is that always the case you
know it seems like hydrogens are
everywhere well no it's not always the
case let me show you an aprodic solvent
so diethyl ether looks like this
diethyl ether looks like this
and just so you know the naming it's an
ether because it has an oxygen and it's
diethyl because it has two ethyl groups
that's one ethyl group right there and
that is the second so it's diethyl
ether now you might say hey this guy
this guy's got hydrogens lying around as
well maybe those can get released but no
these hydrogens are bonded to the carbon
and carbon is not anywhere near as
electronegative as oxygen so these are
not going to be carbon is unlikely to
steal these hydrogen's electrons and
these hydrogens to be loose if they were
bonded to the to the oxygen that would
have been a possibility so in water you
have you know obviously you have hoh
in alcohols
alcohols
you have some maybe carbon chain bonded
to an oxygen which is then bonded to a
hydrogen so in either of these cases
in either water or alcohol you have
these hydrogens where the electron might
be taken by the oxygen because it's so
electronegative and then the hydrogen
floats around anyway that's a review of
protic versus aprotic now in a protic
solvent and this is actually a general
rule of thumb
if a nucleophile is likely to react with
its solvent it will be bad at being a
nucleophile and think about it if it's
reacting with the solvent it's not going
to be able to do this it's not going to
be able to give its electrons away to
what it needs to give it away to maybe
you know what we saw in say an sn2 type
reaction so in a protic solvent what
happens is is the things that are really
electronegative and really small like a
fluoride anion so let me draw a fluoride
anion
a fluoride anion
in
in a protic solvent
in a protic solvent what's going to
happen is it's going to be blocked by
hydrogen bonds so it's it's very
negative right it has a negative charge
and it's also tightly packed as you can
see right here as it it's its electrons
are very close tied in it's much it's a
much smaller
atom or ion in this case and if we
looked at iodide iodide has 53 electrons
many orbitals fluoride or actually
iodide would have 54 it had the same as
iodine plus one fluoride will have 10
electrons 9 from fluorine plus it gains
another one so it's much smaller it's a
much smaller atom
and so when you have water hanging
around it let's say you have something
like water that has a negative charge
water
water is polar
water is polar and actually both of
these are polar so i should write down
polar for both of this this is a polar
polar protic solvent this is a polar
a protic solvent in this case water is
still more electronegative than the
carbon so it still has a partial
negative charge these parts still have a
partial negative water still has partial
negative the hydrogen has a partial
positive charge so it is going to be
attracted to the fluorine and this is
going to happen all around the fluorine
and if these waters are attracted to the
fluorine and kind of forming a shell a
tight shell around it it makes it hard
for fluorine to react
hard
for hard to react hard to
react so it's a worse nucleophile than
say iodide or hydroxide in a protic in a
polar protic solvent hydroxide has the
same issue it's still forming hydrogen
bonds but if you wanted to compare them
hydroxide is sorry iodide is a much is a
much bigger you know maybe i draw it
like this you know i'll draw a valence
shell like this it's a much
it's a much bigger
much bigger ion you know it has all
these electrons in here and so it still
will form hydrogen bonds with the water
it still will form hydrogen bonds with
the hydrogen end of the water because
they're partially positive but it's
going to be less tightly packed and on
top of that iodide is more polarizable
it's more polarizable
so this is polar
polarized
which means that it's electron crowded
so big and you know the valence
electrons are so far away from the
nucleus that they can be influenced by
things and then be more likely to react
so let's say this iodide is getting
close to a carbon that has a partial
positive charge so let's say a carbon is
attached to a i don't know let's attach
it's attached to a bromine and then it's
attached to three hydrogens
we've seen this will have a partial
negative charge it's more
electronegative than the carbon which
will have a partial positive charge and
so when this guy this big guy with the
electrons really far away gets close to
this the electrons are going to more of
the electron cloud is going to be
attracted to the partial positive charge
so it'll get distorted a little bit and
so it is more likely to react in a polar
protic solvent fluor fluoride on the
other hand very tightly packed blocked
by blocked by the hydrogen bonds less
likely to react so if you were to look
at
if you look at the periodic table if you
look at say just the halogens
just the halogens
in a polar in a polar protic solvent the
halides so this would be the ion version
of the halogens the halides iodide it
will be the best nucleophile fluoride
will be the worst so in a polar protic
solvent so let me write this down in
polar protic solvent new color
polar
protic
solvent
then we have a situation where the
iodide is the best nucleophile iodide
followed by bromide followed by
followed by chloride and then last of
all is the fluoride now the exact
opposite true is true in a aprodic
solvent in an a protic solvent the
fluoride would which is you know
fluorine is far more electronegative
fluoride is more basic it wants it it
will be more stable if it is able to
form a bond with something than iodide
iodide is pretty stable it's actually if
you look at a hydrogen
hydrogen iodide it's actually a highly
highly acidic molecule so iodide itself
the conjugate base of hydrogen iodide is
going to be a very bad base so when
you're dealing with an a protic solvent
you go in the direction of basicity and
we're going to learn in the next video
that actually basicity and
nucleophilicity are related but they
aren't the same concept and we're going
to talk about that in a little bit so
but if you're not if you're an a protic
solvent you're no longer as light you're
not reacting with the solvent as much
and then in this situation
fluoride is actually the best
nucleophile followed by chloride
followed by
bromide
followed by iodide so here you're going
in the direction of basicity this is the
best this is the worst in a a protein an
aprotic solvent if it was in a protic
solvent this is flipped around this
becomes the best and this becomes the
worst